out of California where tens of
thousands are under evacuation orders
due to the risk of major flooding the
latest weather system has moved on but
water levels remain dangerously high in
much of the state right now homes like
this one in San Clemente south of Los
Angeles are teetering on the edge of
saturated cliffsides Carter Evans is
south of Santa Cruz where some people
are still waiting to be allowed back
into their homes Carter good morning
good morning Vlad this extreme weather
clearly has a local impact with all of
this flooding but it could be a national
problem you see California grows about
three quarters of the country's fruits
and nuts and for example this is a
strawberry farm and now it's underwater
the crop is ruined but the soil could
also be contaminated possibly delaying
replanting for months
California Farmers appear to be getting
desperate
sacrificing pickup trucks in an effort
to fill a broken Levee
who posted this video says the men were
trying to prevent the Thule River in
central California from inundating an
orchard
on Wednesday Governor Gavin Newsom
surveyed damage in the farming town of
paharo the result of a break in a levy
that's been neglected for decades this
is a known problem the money is there to
fix it when can people expect to see
construction on the solution we have a
five to seven year timeline that has
been pre-established but based upon this
experience no one has patience for five
to seven years across the state almost
90 000 people are facing evacuation
Christopher moredo left his home in the
middle of the night with no shoes what
happened when you went to the shelter
it was full it was full no room no more
space he's been living in his car for
almost a week so this is everything
you've got now this is my home
from now
now the local community is stepping in
with clothes and supplies what do you
want to say to the people who are in
charge of all this well they had to do
something fast I can't imagine what
they're going to do or how they're gonna
survive in here
you know all this has left many
farmworkers out of a job now the
governor says they are all immediately
eligible for 600 relief checks if there
is any good news to come out of all this
you know California's been in an extreme
drought right now and people in Southern
California have been facing severe water
cutbacks well as of right now those
restrictions have been lifted for 7
million people Tony
good news Carter thank you very much